là je vais faire le tour si vous aviez
un truc à dire à un chroniqueur ce soir
ce serait qui voilà un truc à dire mais
chacun notre tour je peux commencer
alors bernard vous pouvez toujours
commencer a dit ça vous ennuie pas oui
oui parce que je pour moi c'est une
belle révélation cette année c'est
matthieu delormeau et
quand il est là il exceptionnel avant je
me méfiais de ces noms mais voilà je ne
trouve d'abord très très bon à nîmes
chroniqueur gentil et son émission là
elle est très bien il est très bien très
très bien cette année je trouve c'était
pas mon avis avant d'acheter j'ai changé
d'avis ouais c'est vrai je le trouve
très très bien il est bien là et mieux
dans sa vie à y aller mais j'irai
brillant il est bon et les années vous
vous sentez bien moi aussi je vous sens
je serai pas nous y tenir je me sens
comme une fleur voilà ça fait longtemps
on attendait qu'est ce que c'est une
saignée quoi une ceni métamorphosé
cette fleur ouais et cloud c'est mon âme
est clos et cloud ouais c'est vrai c'est
pas vous aider à
clore éclore a grandi éclore et vous on
sent que vous étiez comme ça toi et
normand
oui on dirait quelqu'un qui nous a
poussés par la nabe hakim a arrosé il y
avait la graine oui il fallait qu'on
arrose bas c'est vrai il fallait la
prendre et si
oui par rossini oui oui tout l'été là
effectivement je sens que je sais pas
moi de le dire mais je vais je après mon
année mais je vous dis ta rose c'est
vraiment votre diverses personnes
ils sont six
non c'est vrai c'est très gentil après
j'suis pas tous les soirs là aussi c'est
vrai comme vous le dites mais
reconnaissez quelque chose syrie à aa ma
mère et moi aussi je trouve de leurs
beaux bons cette année ouais mais il ya
un mais il se la pète un peu et ce à
quoi il se la pète un peu tu avais dit
il pète un peu haussé ses barrières cela
fait un peu c'est que moi alors je vais
pas répondre négativement à votre mère
donc elle a tout à fait raison
non reconnaissait quelque chose oui il
ya des soirs où je pourrais venir et
jeudi à nourdine le producteur fatigué
je vais pas être bon ça veut dire que ce
soir là ouais je m'assis avènement sur
un salaire par certains le sexy non ma
prestation n'a pas grave aux basses et
boa oui mais qu'est ce que vous me dites
quand il est là ouais ouais les soirs où
je suis quand je sens que j'ai pas faire
alors oui mais alors là je dis rien
oui mais moi je laissais oui mon chéri
c'est comme ça alors c'est tu croyais
nadal à roland garros je le sens pas je
sais pas le faire non pas donc forcément
eu et gilles et vj rallye je disais je
joue pratiquement tous les matches donc
forcément voilà mais non c'est vrai mais
mériterait bien c'était plus de granma
par deux fois gilles raveaud qu'on est
payé à l'émission à l'origine ce soit
bravo voilà bravo barre il y en a
d'autres qui devraient dire ça
vous les avez quelque chose à dire à
quelqu'un peut-être oui alors alice
j'oserais dire que c'est la meilleure
chroniqueuse pour moi elle est drôle
pertinente est là pour dénoncer faire
tomber des puissants
j'aimais les questions juridiques à lui
poser est ce que légalement vous allez
droit d'être aussi belle
[Applaudissements]
sinon sur un chroniqueur vous l'avez
trouvé moins bon hier quoi moi j'étais
un peu déstabilisé
exactement ce qu'ils ont sur le
chroniqueur à qui vous avez un truc à
dire ni un peu négative tout en menant à
mathieu alors pour et non non et non
négatif mais la cua négatif oui oui bah
mathieu pas mal bah pourquoi il a visité
bat mathieu août c'est ça que je voulais
dire que quand il est revenu on sait
qu'on s'entendait pas du tout aidé bien
faire est tout à fait voilà c'est un peu
la guerre on s'est déjà envolé très fort
et cette année j'ai appris à le
connaître et je trouve qu'il est très
bon j'ai toujours trouvé que les détails
mais on est devenus amis mais sinon je
devrais je m'entends avec tout le monde
on te demande pas de malentendu on te
parle en garde gilles verdez sait faire
la gentille coulibaly moi j'ai plusieurs
problèmes avec des gens autour de la
table mais attention est ce que tu peux
teinture dedans bien sûr ouais j'aurais
pu choisir montiel mais le pire c'est
castaldi
franchement à part être votre ami je ne
sais pas à quoi il sert gevrey qui pète
de temps en temps mais on l'entend plus
ça c'est pour réveiller auxerrois il a
rien à dire même la regarder il sait pas
quoi répondre c'est cool pour l'acheter
du cul
jour de la vérité mais en plus il nous a
il nous a unis nous amie valérie benaïm
clijsters à la mcl auster j'aurais bien
je retrouve les missions km
il compte en ligne les autres ouais donc
à la limite combos plus mauvais mais
fait le chez toi
mais là je suis pas libre belgique comme
vous bailly les choses qu'on peut te
répondent ils vas-y
gilles pour moi c'est le meilleur allié
de la casse à écrire à north bay les
traits jean louis joly alors je vous
dirais vérité c'est que moi la
différence à signer à tout en émettant
des bons cyril non je rigole tout le
temps mais non non non il a un avis sur
tout et il ya 200 ans on a vu surtout ce
pas
travailler alors c'est là je
sais que tu tombes garde gilles verdez
sully ça ouais ouais il rebondit jeu
driver béjaoui je dérape chez mon ami
qu'est la non pas du tout à fait la
différence c'est que moi je veux jamais
parasiter les missions non mais ne pas
parasiter là
je fais mon travail je lève la main vous
ne devez pas la parole nature et jamais
je suis bien élevé monsieur tu as
différentes caisses cas mathieu qu'est
ce que les gars est non match l'arrière
mathieu qu'il défend parce que j'y
dépose pas là quelque chose j'y vais
très très bon sur la forme par les sur
les zones survolées nord s'il peut le
faire tout le temps c'est ce que vous
voulez je peux le faire là aujourd'hui
on comprend pas ce que vous dites
qu'on voit aussi le jour du
mois c'est trop confiants on comprend
pas alors maintenant sur gil brésil est
très fort sur la forme et on sait que la
télévision c'est beaucoup de la forme
litres on s'est un peu de légumes
ça exactement ça ferait à la forme il
est très doué mais c'est du côté où il
commence systématiquement pas j'ai
enquêté mais une fois sur deux c'est fou
non c'est la feuille la personne est
vrai il a pas eu là vous mentir je ne
sais pas ce que dans danse avec les
stars sur danse avec les stars sur les
quelques dossiers que moi je connais
très bien je vois le nombre de conneries
qui sort alors vous voyez que je voulais
avec un aplomb gigantesque comme la
forme est très bonne ça passe je vous
dis la vérité les équipes travaillent à
4 de bassora sud en étroite
collaboration et qui veut renaître et
c'est lui qui appelle tout le monde et
c'est lui qui inquiète le plus et je
peux vous dire si vous travaillez comme
gilbert dette vous verriez bellerive sur
606 que la différence entre toi et moi
que l'essentiel de mon temps et mes
infos gelé consacra syrie alors que toi
tu les consacre aux autres chaînes pour
vendre pédauque moisi
et les noms les séries à 18h52 je peux
vous dire j'aime l'ambiance j'adore mais
différenciées entre toi et ton ami
bernard tapie de 10 est très bien il ya
les gens qui commentent et les gens qui
font toute ta vie tu a commenté joue
très bien il fait et bien sûr mais tu
n'as jamais animé dans la jamais produit
tu le fais tu n'as jamais aéro et du
fer est tombé sur la région sur ses news
bon bah tout est dit voilà n'ont pas
oublié tes pas le seul voilà il ya un
moment tu parle que de choses que tu ne
connais moi je vais vous dire pourquoi
je viens rue gilbert déséquilibre il
serait fort il a beaucoup d'infos et
pour moi jle ne change rien tu es au top
voilà je te le dis est vraiment bravo
d'ailleurs adressé jeudi et tu
travailles tu travailles et je sais que
voilà tu as pas d une relation
sentimentale très facile
et moi et moi je serai toujours là pour
toi mon fils et je le sais les moments
difficiles et y en a eu vous êtes
toujours là et je sais que tu travailles
géraldine est ce que tu te dois de dire
non moi je trouve qu'effectivement
gilles boss impressionnants cette année
sur un impressionnant c'est une sorte de
valeur sur april a des avis mais
catastrophique equities y aura mais moi
je vais bien je vais défoncer comme quoi
en fait insupportable en fait ils
doivent résister à ce point-là malades
dans le principe de l'émission c'est que
tout le monde a son avis voilà il gisait
depuis le début du jeu les voilà la vrai
que j'ai pas été tendre avec lui mais
moi je passe une très très bonne saison
parce que je dois dire que je suis très
très bien entouré ou sarrio j'entends
par là j'irai pas d'oublier ou que
j'entends c'est franchement pour moi une
révélation il est bon camara en fait
c'est un peu comme si tu es mon petit
garçon c'est ça mon fiston on se marre
on a des fous rires ah c'est comme la
latte après un coup parce que je sais
que tu es intéressé au dossier mes
fistons c'est bon c'est un peu comme un
maman jeanne oui j'aime bien mal d'écart
donc voilà et ce soir raymond que ce
soit bernard et ben franchement je suis
ton grand père mais bon je trouve que
c'est vraiment une il ya une très bonne
ambiance bravo oui isabelle achats me
disais si vous avez un truc à dire sur
un pas négatif mais voilà un truc
humbert j'ai beaucoup de mal avec les
idées du monde valérie reviennent au
mais je ne m'attendais pas à la can 2006
mais jamais
des bons jours au matin alors moi
empêcher le dit
j'adore béatrice il adore elle est très
sympathique mais je ne partage pas ses
idées mais préfère être avec valérie
enfin s'accordant mellal est la seule
audi mais parie qu'avec les gens qui ont
résidé la hauteur en
france ici tu vois donc convié comme
gilles et désagréable tout le monde est
trouve ça super et quand moi je dis un
truc pas sympa tout six noms mais on s'y
attendait pas on s'y attendait pas mais
vraiment pas rater au japon dépasse
avoue que c'est ça c'est certain il
apprendre avec avait ça en même temps tu
appris auprès d'apple emploi du
bea ça non ouais ça va et je voulais
dire si je devais dire quelque chose à
un chroniqueur s'est s'arrêté gilles
parce que je ne suis jamais d'accord
avec gilles sur le plateau mais je dois
dire que gilles dans la vie quand je les
rencontre et quand j'ai découvert tout
le monde ça a été vraiment le plus
adorable vraiment c'est un amour et
c'est le docteur jekyll et mr hyde quand
ils rentrent sur le plateau et devient
assez incisif et bon voilà mais la télé
faire sur le plateau béatrice très bon
mais il faut ça il faut que les gens
changent la vie et je lui en suis très
reconnaissante parce que quand on arrive
dans une nouvelle équipe vous êtes sûr
qu'il voudrait pas ouais non même pas en
train d'apprendre qu'il est bon dans le
métro finalement mais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je ne répondrai pas
si
j'aime la contradiction cependant ça
aussi que je suis là pour donner mon
avis avec des états bien raison voilà
c'est fait un tagueur [ __ ]
pourquoi pas vraiment l'américaine alors
il ya isabelle qui nous jettent toujours
gardé sa peau quand toute l'année merci
mme aziza et
sur les deux blondes ma guillaume et
mathieu parce qu'avant honnêtement il
vous montre et rires j'ai toujours peur
qui me tombe sur le coin de la gueule et
ça arrive à sa part libre ça va arriver
l'atelier giroux et je suis pas inquiète
et guillaume et mathieu me font vraiment
beaucoup rire series ou la boucherie et
dieu sait que c'est souvent mon
détriment non mais je le suis assez
d'accord avec mathieu je suis désolé
mais sur certains secteurs que je
connais moi aussi c'est pas toujours
juste merci ma jolie c'est pour moi
c'est souvent justes et ravira les fans
en cas de poussée des choix des
symphonies les jamais de mon avis je les
décris ces peintures votre métier il est
très rarement mon avis on bosse et pour
moi c'était voilà cc savez c'est comme
en classe et un élève s'est tous les
professeurs aimerait avoir un élève
comme gilbert desport dans leurs classes
inférieures à castanet
vous les envoyez un petit mot comme sur
géraldine qu'elle est quand même la
seule franchement la seule buback ovide
et tous qui vous rend un peu dedans nous
les mecs on n'ose pas bon ça va des
massacres mais qui vous rendent un peu
dedans à chaque fois au prix peut-être
de temps en temps donner mais sûrement
lll vous rentre dedans et c'est très
bien comme ça on en discute pas mais
après il a bon après nom ne soit pas
trop de poids
ce qui va en fait ça sur ses sacs et ses
vendeurs gilbert des failles madiot sont
regardés simard ont dû foule sur plein
de sujets mais je te le dis mais fou ça
match aller et pourtant je laime mes
défauts parfois je me dis mais qui remet
on peut dire des conneries pareilles ça
c'est vrai est serré mais je la dois
écouter
leurs alice alors soient dans sa vous
êtes content d'être là je suis ravi des
alouettes rappel vous êtes au barreau de
paris tout est fait voilà vous allez
revenir connaissez le barreau de paris
mathieu oui bien sûr bonjour est avocat
au barreau de mykonos
[Rires]
mon appel oui donc oui oui donc ça va ça
va traiter le plus gentil avec vous
quand vous êtes arrivé c'est gilles
guillaume mais alors excusez moi mais si
on pourrait se calmer un peu parce que
c'est trop tôt je crois et tout le monde
a été très gentil et je voudrais virage
et aline à quel point je les admire
parce que je la trouve belle élégante
toujours pertinente et je trouve qu'elle
incarne parfaitement la femme puissante
et c'est ce dont on a besoin à la télé
pas pu savoir
et vous avez vu géraldine est très
souvent et franchement je dis 100% du
temps je suis pas d'accord car dit c'est
à dire y'a pas un sujet car oui il ya
pas un sujet où je suis d'accord avec
vous et pourtant j'ai dit que c'était là
peut-être la meilleure cette année avec
lille donc voyez comme ça comme complète
dans ce livre pas d'accord avec moi donc
c'est la force de l'émission c'est
exactement mais c'est vrai parce que
vraiment surtout surtout surtout je n'en
peux plus moi je trouve que c'est très
bien que ça traduira ensuite de dire que
d'associer meilleur au temps passé sur
le plateau ah ah bah c'est comme ça là
non si vous faites pas tous les tournois
voiture comment situez va t'on dit mon
droit comment tu peux être premier
mondial tu fais un grand chelem dans
l'année nan mais vous qui aimez le foot
et yallo en fait mathieu jeu par le
patron
c'est comme si que p&g disais que je
fais que 20 matches de championnat ray
et barbant en exemple vous qui aimez le
foot oui comme si un joueur de foot ne
jouait pas tous les matches et sans
jouer tous les matches c'est celui qui
marque plus ah non mais qui a dit vous
marquez plus bas à lui et moi
à
benjamin serre ils
n'ont écouté je vous trouve un peu dur
avec moi mais écoutez j'entends ce que
vous dites je vais prendre la parole
plus souvent je veux m'imposer je vais
marcher sur les autres marchés personne
et je vais match si je marchais sur les
autres et empêcher une surprise pour
vous je vais faire plus de plus de bruit
mais des chroniqueurs les chroniqueurs
écoutez franchement chacun a son rôle
s'arrête je suis vraiment agacé cette
année pas par gide qui a un avis
toujours du même côté et ça devient
insupportable
c'est vrai que c'est essentiellement à
votre avis mais moi oui moi j'ai mon
avis et si tu n'écoutes et abat que tu
le connais très bien le coin t il aux
règles parliez tu défends toujours la
veuve et l'orphelin t on du côté sur le
raciste sur le discours alors c'était la
même chose et c'est là ce droit soit
parce qu'au bout d'un moment tu n'es pas
crédible en fait l'étude statut
décribiliser même dans son propos et
dans des roches est vrai que la coupe
des maladies bhl
calme des mois
la famille fait-il là c'est toi
qui m'as pas ce qu'ils disent pas plus
que vous bref est en fait possible
avec moi tu as raison c'est s'échangeait
à 114 ces enquêtes se résume en fait à
google guba ses propos voilà donc non
mais je voyais pas de jaloux de chinois
je suis jaloux de personne et surtout
pas de gilles verdez et mon cerveau est
moins intelligent santé mondiale se voit
avec les fiscs aujourd'hui tu as bien
préparé l'émission
06 12
mai départ à venir de varier un peu ça
que ce qui hélas le meuble à la sln